weinfreunde und herzlich willkommen zu
einer runde wer bin ich weiß nicht ob
ihr die zettelchen lesen könnt wenn er
die wir uns gegenseitig geschrieben
haben sonst nicht die nachher einfach
mal unten einfach ein in der
nachbearbeitung ich bin erst mal
zusammen mit patrick mit grant kraft und
mit escape ihr seht man video
eingeblendet wie wir durch köln gefahren
sind
deswegen ist er nicht als provisorisch
und wir sind jeder ein einzelner youtube
und stellt uns jetzt so fragen an
jeweils und die namen für die
eingeblendet und wir schicken jetzt
einmal wäre die erste frage stellen darf
wollt ihr müssen wir auch nicht
provisorisch stunden aber ich bin profi
und somit papier schere stein papier
dankbar 44
ich bin ich männlich bin ich habe ich
über zwei fragen bin ich ein deutscher
youtube bin ich deutscher habe ich über
100 bin ich menschlich mache ich das
fest
habe ich über 300.000 ich glaube nicht
ok will ich meine ja display bin ich
weiblich
ein bisschen aber nein
wenn ich ein englischer youtuber also
jetzt frage ich englisch englisch
englisch aus england spiel minecraft
macht es hier komme die das männchen mit
kommen deine mutter als ansprüche
gute keine bälle früh alles klar dann
komm ich aus der comedy ecke main kanal
über den über 5000 abonnenten
südländer
meine hoffnung habe ich über 5 millionen
abonnenten
was mache ich so informativ videos wo
ich informationen und wissen oder hab
ich mit derjenigen person schon mal
aufgenommen haben sich hier
dies ist in deutschland bin ich alleine
auf meinem staat kein recht lang könnte
also meisten kommen in den videos so
gemütliche sachen muss man ein wort hat
erklärt zweikämpfe
damals - was ich ausschließlich kommen
die videos oder auch so was wie
glock challenges oder so was also macht
den hauptkanal herrlich saftig rechts
und links waren ein gerader und jetzt
weiter denkt dann war ich in minecraft
war okay oder
ja ich glaube da war sogar dabei hast du
gefragt
ja ich glaub mal dabei sitzt derjenige
mit uns hier gerade gesagt ist gesagt in
der runde aber nicht schaffen schnell
wieder aufgenommen ich meine ja auch auf
meinem kanal
würde jetzt auch kein kenne aber mit dem
aufenthalt ausländische wurzeln
es gibt eine art fotos sind perfekt
beschreibt die tiefe gegangen weiter
gehalt ist der schwarzer habe ich
schwarz bin ich in einem youtube
netzwerk habe ich zwei beine habe ich
viele verschiedene formate also formate
kann man macht halt auch so eine idee
und macht kosten
ich kenne ihn wenn ich da drauf ist
denkt gar nicht des blogs also bin ich
der beste
ich habe ich kontakt
aber kann man sagen
also habe ich unter 100.000 autos bei
gott nicht stimmt ja die haben viel
gemacht
über 100 frage kennst du einen safe
ich habe echt keine ahnung ich weiß echt
fragt euch wenn ich vitali oder wider
ich bin eine einzelne person
heute machen kontroverse inhalte da
liegt aber falsch mit der ersten frage
aber okay dann ja ich hab echt wenn wir
nicht endlich kam ich in amerika ist
nicht so krass aus mit dem youtube den
ich kenne und schnitzel sind zwei
personen
die lok ist macht aber alle schon grüße
ja aber ich sah keine einzige
eigenschaft die die luft ist auch haben
haben diese beiden das alter vor allem
warte noch ein großer teil eine
verbindliche eigenschaft diese
verbindliche eigenschaft ist sogar ein
kanal vorhanden ist der kommt auch
kontron com die nockis sind nicht nur
cool trendy und zwerge sondern auch
willingen ja du bist zwillinge comedy
komplize die ganze nacht die trentino
meine freunde das war's dann jetzt mit
diesem video wir haben das ganze ein
bisschen sehr sehr der 100 grad hin
geschissen alter sehr viel hilfestellung
gemacht war ein bisschen chaotisch wir
wollten auch erste challenge aufnehmen
aber dazu hatten wir keine zeit mehr um
das irgendwie und coole challenge
aussuchen
deswegen hoffe ich dass das auch in
ordnung war und wir sehen uns einem
nächsten video wieder denke auf jeden
fall die alle kanäle aus der
beschreibung